in Bitcoin millionaire news oh I don't
know one of those I smell Jobar
was it a burp or fart I don't know what
she burn funny yeah we'll leave it in I
fought all the time so it's payback baby
pikas toes wait wait submitted by Tigers
a little fat circles they look like
mochi balls I like it when Tigers trying
to figure out if he should smile or not
he's just smile can do it I like calling
his feet dirty been a millionaire team
built a functional Doctor Octopus what'd
I say
octopus in Spanish that's the spider-man
villain right yeah dr. Octavius that's
tech his middle name oh really oh look
at that coincidence I think not see I'm
the one that Titus submitted it
his togs his mochi toes does he put his
feet in his mouth no he doesn't there's
always babies that do that yeah maybe
not this one
why not or what do you say it so funny
like it's funny Oh cuz he said some
babies and it said not this one cuz if
he doesn't I don't know how you say that
alright wait what do you mean was there
like an underlying thing you think I
said I thought you were trying to so I
was trying to read it alright so anyway
this millionaire team he invested in
Bitcoin when he was 12 years old he is
now 19 years old he first invested a
thousand dollars 100,000 dollars at 12
from his grandma oh I know this kid you
do what's his name I don't know about
the [ __ ] Octavius thing but there was
a video on him by a news channel he
didn't make Doctor Octopus yet but he
was already on the news for being a
millionaire on Bitcoin and his grandma
gave him some money
you asked where he got the money from
that's the only thing you know because I
didn't know it before what I didn't know
it before the the fact about his grandma
because there could be other kids that
may not million-dollar that could be
this child turned a thousand dollars
into Millions
he had faith in Bitcoin after his
brother took him to Occupy Wall Street
protests oh oh see families in wealth
become wealthier because they have their
have access to knowledge and research my
nephew right now you're gonna have
access all because people that were
going to occupy wait for you guys the
blow it's like a blue chopper you know
you come out people that are gonna
occupy wall street people were poor
nobody brother part of the show them
that like hey this is why you can't
trust the banking system and this is
probably why cryptocurrency is the
future
yeah and so it's like oh [ __ ] I can see
what you transfer like education yeah I
mean yeah like that's the type of stuff
that a lot of like Asian immigrants
don't get just don't know English so if
they see a bunch of people playing bongo
drums at the park they're like oh yeah
his parents met at Stanford while they
were oh yeah they're all smart well
they're getting their doctors and
electrical engineering and physics and
pretty much they has entire families
breezy oh yeah that's what I'm talking
about people don't understand that part
like as Asian immigrant parents they
can't teach their kids the tools in
order to survive in this system per se
they just know work hard things happen
yeah are just immigrant parents yeah
yeah one I can almost be for my personal
speech that's why so it's like a lot of
these kids who knew about scholarships
we only finally found about scholarships
later on yeah it's like oh what the [ __ ]
there's free money you know okay so if I
found out in college that's all I got
rims from my car mmm that's financial
aid for me but what a scholarship yeah
anyway so this Tina's name is Eric
shinmin this is what he looks like and
this is the doc ock suit oh wow so he
invests in a lot of he was like a
youtuber yeah he does he invest in a lot
of projects
and I'm just an investor yeah he's even
doing this ongoing collaboration with
NASA oh wow yeah so one of his mentor's
is kid he's a ten-year-old even has a
mentor yeah is losing ten year old mint
that would be so dope if you're 19 and
you have a ten-year-old no following
along yes I was like that total JIT I
pictured this like special child like a
ten-year-old like spiritual like yogi or
some [ __ ] I'm legit like a reincarnated
Dalai Lama
on the phone calling his 10 year old
mentor like right now he goes hey what
are you doing right now have a question
asked hold on my mom's making me a white
bread sandwich you know Wonder Bread no
no I pictured like a like a like like
that Life of Pi [ __ ] straight-up
Indian kid that's he that's like a yoga
master oh that's right with the robe on
once and a lot yeah I watched Life of Pi
again dude yeah so he made this mr.
Peters so that 10 year old he suffers
from hypermobility and so that gives him
a lot of aches and pains in his tendons
oh he's too flexible yeah he's too
flexible lucky so if he came up with the
idea of like oh you know it'd be really
cool to make a real-life Doctor Octopus
prosthesis and so they ended up getting
all these scientists together and
funding this project and within six
months they actually made it so I'm
gonna show you guys a clip damn hey I
was just I fell in love with the project
and I found a really great group of
really talented people to work on it and
it's just become one of the coolest
things in the world and there's just so
much you can do with this my name is
we've been working on making dr. Raja
Pisans when I was 8 years old I went to
comic-con and I remember just how fun it
was and - just how cool that was seeing
all the costumes and us and thinking
just then I can make something as cool
as that and then I thought I can make it
cool Wow I would never [ __ ] leave my
chair
that's what that bill there needed for
the sprays [ __ ] spray all those
things dude if I had this [ __ ] you and I
would be rolling dude you just see right
now I would [ __ ] you up
I'll put you in [ __ ] two knee bars
and you could tap it I'm not releasing
so this is just a double was battling
like fat spider-man it just it can only
pick up like lightweight things it can't
really do a lot but the fact that
they've already came up with this
technology and all because they had to
create their own custom 3d printer to
even print this oh no Eric is saying
that he's gotten a lot of inquiries
about it like from other people that are
interested to actually make this thing
like real-life scale where you can pick
up an actual car and like help in
construction or helping in like surgery
like having the doctor have all these
like just future that's gonna be crazy
cuz you know what's gonna happen is like
you know your brain is gonna develop
these extra limbs like intelligence it's
gonna be able to use it it's gonna be
like I'm is gonna be [ __ ] cool Oh
like your brain will adapt to think
those limbs are actually part of the
body yeah
like a phantom body part yeah yeah hard
to drive me everywhere that's all
Oh like a Tesla or like an uber driver
or humming David they're coming it's
around the corner I really do want that
I want or a butler a driver yeah you
know like have you guys seen oh you guys
haven't seen this film is called updated
have you seen it upgraded oh yeah I've
created I heard about it
[ __ ] dope like it's been a while
since I like the sci-fi movie like that
but just do something small in the
beginning of the film it's just like
automated cards and you just sit there
and you get your work done
like Minority Report what's my report
never - mine are do what Tom Cruise they
predict that you're gonna commit a crime
I know it goes I just know you're dumb
so I was gonna explain it - really done
really yeah really you make a comparison
you what let's make any sense yeah cuz
you're dumb you compare yourself to
yourself
Jesus idiot anyways let's move on I like
future moon didn't she didn't she didn't
use the example pregnant women put woman
babe CG she gave up she gave up thank
you I do actually owe you one because I
got scared for a second I just got be up
this morning being scared no one beats
you up
I can't run away I don't have any
strength to be too freakin liar you are
said there's video proof there is and I
felt bad bigger group of you topping
before anything even happened
you just wait dude I'm gonna get these
bars i'ma submit your ass how I explain
for people I don't know what you talking
about oh if you go oh I don't even know
who posted it Ron did Ron posted this
man put me putting me into an armbar i
reposted it cuz I thought was so funny
stories really got he's gonna be on my
brow yes his log of B being harassed and
berated he spit in my eye
he planted his wiener between David's
butt cheeks and made a hot dog
[Music]